[Music]
on this sunday night pride and pain
the growing number of threats against
the
lgbtq2 plus community we were all scared
we were heartbroken a troubling trend in
canada and beyond
a potential flight path to more profits
these are extraordinary circumstances
why business could soon soar for
low-cost airlines
the mystery of long coved they just were
kind of like come back in a few years
and maybe we'll know more the mission to
cure the suffering
and uh rats but that's not a bad thing
we're hoping they can actually get
closer to victims training rodents to be
lifesavers
global national with bara nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
june is typically a month of
celebrations for the lgbtq two-plus
community and its allies but during this
year's pride events there are stark
reminders that hate still exists
this week a drag show was canceled in
victoria after organizers received
threats and similar incidents have
played out across the country and in the
u.s in our top story tonight mike
trolley examines this disturbing trend
and what's being done to address it
in northern idaho 31 suspected white
nationalists wearing riot gear were
arrested before they could disrupt a
pride event and near san francisco more
hate at a library's drag queen story
hour did you guys call the cops in the
form of white power signs and homophobic
slurs
lgbtq activists expect a certain amount
of hate every year during pride month
but there's been so much in 2022 it's
proving difficult to track
yeah you know part of my work is trying
to like keep an eye on like anti-28 and
it feels like it's just an onslaught
right now and the incidents are not
unique to the us a victoria drag show
that was billed as family friendly was
canceled after the venue received a
threatening phone calls we were all
scared we were heartbroken in regina a
rainbow painted walkway and statue were
defaced and in tillsonburg ontario a
threatening note sealed in a plastic bag
was left next to torn pride flags
still the perception of an increase in
pride related hate is entirely anecdotal
in 2019 statistics canada estimated
there are 223 000 self-reported hate
crimes of all types in canada yet law
enforcement reported only
1951 crimes during that same period
meaning less than one percent of
perceived hate crimes were reported what
is far more evident to anti-hate groups
is how homophobic and transphobic
discussions have gone mainstream i mean
i you know i think i could care less how
you dress or what you call yourself but
this is not liberation this is the dark
ages even major league baseball is an
immune five members of the tampa bay
rays refused to wear the pride logo on
their uniforms citing their religious
beliefs and a worry they would be
encouraging a gay lifestyle i think it's
coming here and it's something we're not
ready to uh to deal with or to meet
head-on i'm really worried like what
does it say of our community spaces
aren't safe
that is a crisis point to me one of the
goals of pride is to remove stigmas
around the lgbtq community
clearly more work needs to be done
microlight global news toronto
hearings on the u.s capitol riot will
continue this week and we're expecting
to see more evidence of what the
committee calls an attempted coup by
former president donald trump on tuesday
state officials are going to speak about
how they were pressured by trump to
overturn local election results in a
desperate attempt to hold on to the
white house jennifer johnson has more
including how trump is retaliating
former president donald trump is firing
back at the january 6 committee saying
their findings could never be admitted
in a court of law this is not a
congressional investigation this
horrible situation that's wasting
everyone's time in a speech before the
faith and freedom coalition trump took
aim at his closest inner circle at the
white house former vice president mike
pence and former attorney general bill
barr who testified trump became detached
from reality after losing the election i
think what we're presenting before the
american people certainly would rise to
a level of criminal involvement by a
president i certainly think the
president is guilty of knowing what he
did seditious conspiracy
the committee is laying out a case that
the former president demanded vice
president pence not certify the election
results on january 6 and later tried to
strong-arm election officials in several
states to overturn results in their
jurisdictions they clearly tried
to get the vice president to throw the
actual votes out and replace electors
with the losing candidate and it looks
like that's
in the works for the next election as
well it's a grave concern trump twice
impeached but never removed from office
is still claiming fraud cost him the
election as he teases he may run again
for president in 2024. i need 11 000
votes give me a break on tuesday former
georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger will testify after the
2020 election he taped a phone call with
trump where the former president asked
him to find enough votes to illegally
overturn the results in georgia if
someone has no respect for the rule of
law and believes only in their own power
in an obsessive narcissistic way there's
little that can deter that person but
there are things that can fortify
us
against them and that is an important
part of the committee's work the
bipartisan lawmakers hope to build a
case for the department of justice to
bring criminal charges against trump
after a 10-month investigation that's
their goal as trump continues to declare
his innocence
jennifer johnson global news washington
in quebec almost 200 people have been
ordered out of their homes over fears of
a landslide
residents in this segnay neighborhood
spent their saturday night scrambling to
pack up their belongings last monday a
landslide swept away an empty house in
the area prompting a first round of
evacuations the fire department says the
ground is still very unstable and could
trigger a catastrophe sagnay's mayor
says the evacuees could be out of their
homes for months
violent crime is on the rise in
manitoba's capital with the number of
homicides in winnipeg now on track to
surpass its annual record and what's
more worrying
an alarming number of young people
teenagers are getting involved marnie
blunt reports tonight on the renewed
urgency to help those most at risk
shootings stabbings and deadly assaults
another year of violence gripping the
city of winnipeg we're seeing a spike in
violent crime in winnipeg right now as
of mid-june 25 winnipeggers have lost
their lives to violent crime including
rebecca contoir a young woman whose
partial remains were found outside an
apartment building in mid-may and at the
start of the year a winnipeg man found
dead in his car in a cinboine park
resulting in a 15 and 17 year old being
charged with second degree murder mitch
berbiner commits countless hours to
outreach work he says violent crime
usually spikes in the summer months but
they're also seeing an uptick in young
offenders and victims as the age of the
people involved we're seeing a lot of
kids a lot of teenagers
involved in that right now kids
are
exposed to more earlier
they're out on their own they're
struggling
you know and we're just seeing younger
younger kids at risk the violence also
prompting renewed calls for swifter
action to be taken to protect the most
vulnerable manitoba and especially
winnipeg is
is coined as ground zero for violence
against indigenous women and girls and
two spirit community so it is
it is critical it is a critical state
that we're in right now with one
non-profit calling for a 24 7 safe space
for those fleeing the violence we know
one of the women who recently was
murdered was looking for 24 7 safe space
at the time as for bourboneer he says
he'll continue reaching out to those at
risk and hopefully get them on the right
path i'm discouraged i'm not tired i'm
not burned out i'm
just working hard we're all working hard
we're all doing our best
over the past three years winnipeg has
seen climbing violent crime rates
breaking a record number of homicides in
2019 at 44. an alarming trend that only
appears to be carrying over into 22.
farah
thank you marty that's marnie blunt in
winnipeg for us tonight with westjet
announcing plans it will focus primarily
on western canada flair airlines now
feels the sky's the limit after clearing
up concerns with federal authorities
about whether or not it's canadian owned
industry observers say there is an
opportunity for flair to increase its
market share and as ann gaviola reports
it's poised to fly high during the
summer travel boom with its ultra cost
fares
call it revenge travel call it pent-up
demand whatever the name people are
itching to fly after years of
uncertainty an ultra low-cost carrier
flare airlines is set to capitalize on
this travel boom what we're seeing is
really strong booking starting to come
through for the summer period airfares
across the board are about 30 percent
higher than in 2019 and discounts may be
just the ticket for passengers feeling
squeezed at the pumps and just about
everywhere else if they can really keep
costs low
and offer that offer out much cheaper
ticket prices to consumers
i think that means they're going to get
a lot of demand and so i think the
prospects are very good for atlantic
flair but it's a turbulent time for the
industry the edmonton-based carrier like
its competition is dealing with labor
shortages and sky-high jet fuel costs
these are extraordinary circumstances we
have the most efficient fleet and
therefore not only is that great for the
environment but it's also means that for
every mile flow on we'll burn less gas
than our competitors
and who can forget the headaches and
delays passengers are dealing with at
pearson the country's busiest airport
the federal government says it's hiring
hundreds more employees to deal with
travel volumes we haven't seen since
pre-pandemic but it's going to take time
go early
and that's the advice we're giving to
all of our passengers
the um issues that pierce in a complex
and multi-dimensional this passenger
rights advocate says the biggest beef
with flair is customer service i'm
hearing a lot of complaints about people
booking a flight for a given day that's
like getting cancelled and then being
offered a flight three four five or
seven days later
that's unacceptable according to federal
rules because flair is considered a
small carrier it isn't obligated to do
more than that we're not perfect um
that's for sure i think your canada
council 10 percent of flights through
pearson you know the weekend before last
it's an industry-level problem
passengers should pack some patience too
ann gaviola global news toronto
and coming up from boats to planes to
trains the travel restrictions that are
changing tomorrow
plus long covid changes lives one
researcher's passion to help those with
lingering symptoms
more changes are coming for travelers
starting tomorrow people boarding trains
or planes in canada will no longer have
to show proof of vaccination they'll
still have to wear masks throughout
their journey the federal government
says travelers coming to canada but who
are starting their journey in another
country must still follow all
requirements there for vaccinations and
testing that includes cruise ships
and new efforts are underway to unravel
the mystery surrounding long covid most
people who contract cove in 19 fully
recover but about 10 to 20 percent of
coveted survivors experience a variety
of mid and long-term effects according
to the world health organization and by
those estimates there could be at least
390 000 so-called long-haulers in canada
now the symptoms they can range from
fatigue to chest pain to anxiety and
depression as ross lord reports
researchers are working to gather more
data and ease the trauma of those
affected
amy tenenbaum shook off the omicron
variant in january or so she thought a
few weeks later she developed breathing
problems then she collapsed while
walking home i had a really fast
rapid pounding heart even at rest
and
chest tightness chest pain combined with
other symptoms like constant fatigue
amy's long covet forced her to give up
her job as a server despite being double
vaccinated with no underlying conditions
she can barely walk forced to use a
wheelchair to get around
from doctors there's confusion they just
were kind of like well we can't help you
here we don't know anything about it
come back in a few years and maybe we'll
know more editor carlos hernandez
castillo a researcher at dalhousie
university castillo plans to analyze
brain imaging of long covet victims
looking for patterns that could lead to
public health guidelines on treatment so
when somebody gets sick
the people in the hospital know what to
do after and what they need to
analyze or like maybe test in the
patients to know if they need extra
treatment or like follow-up it's tough
slogging considering long-haulers suffer
from various combinations of more than a
dozen symptoms
everything from brain fog to unexplained
bruising and rashes and unshakeable
exhaustion my speech will change
i slur or you can't articulate castillo
hopes to coordinate his two-year
research project with similar studies
being launched in toronto london ontario
and in mexico we need to combine data
from different sources to be able to
find out those patterns we want to make
like a map of exactly which functions
are getting affected from coming amy
tenenbaum just graduated from dalhousie
she plans to pursue a graduate degree
her strength wavering but her spirit
unbroken
ross lord global news halifax
sharing their stories ahead the vital
human rights tasks being done overseas
with the help of our journalists
as you may have noticed one global
national correspondent hasn't been on
air much lately and with good reason our
mike armstrong is in the democratic
republic of the congo working with
journalists for human rights a canadian
organization helping to train
journalists while promoting human rights
and gender equality here's a look at
what mike's been up to and what it's
meant to him
[Music]
this has been an experience
from the minute you leave the airport
and head downtown you realize kinshasa
is a little different
there's a battle they have about a
million times a day and here it is two
cars fighting over two inches
this isn't an easy place to do a lot of
things including reporting
over the last two months i've been
working with local journalists a few of
the newsrooms actually did stories on
the seminars reformatter michael
armstrong venus
i've also been in the field shooting and
editing stories with reporting teams
with saiyan tv i visited an orphanage
that might have to close that would put
these kids on the streets
with artesia we did a couple of stories
about a fishing village
and with digital congo we visited the
local downtown market to talk about the
same problem canadians are struggling
with inflation ah they're not happy
either
the goal has been to maybe hopefully
help if you want to have a healthy
democracy you tend to need a healthy
media so global kind of loaned two of
its journalists out to
journalists for human rights
my colleague rachel gilmore from our
online division has been working in
tunisia now jhr is based in toronto but
does work in several countries in africa
and the middle east they have all sorts
of programs promoting equality and human
rights
at its office in kinshasa last month it
was training journalists to become human
rights trainers themselves
and then two days later those trainers
delivered to other journalists
just in my time here there have been
meetings with women's rights groups
conferences with news directors
and a meeting with government officials
where jhr is trying to change the legal
system so that women who are victims of
sexual assault don't have to pay to
press charges
it's hard to compare problems we might
complain about in canada with the ones
people experience every day here
prices may be exploding but people in
this country are already starving about
30 million people here don't have enough
to eat
add to that violence from militias in
eastern parts of the country and
tensions with neighboring rwanda there
is real fear things could spiral out of
control
but through all of that i've met men and
women who work hard journalists who do
the job under conditions i've had
trouble believing
in newsrooms here computers are a luxury
even pens are hard to come by
and how about reading a live newscast
lights that never stop flickering
they do it all with dedication and
professionalism
now there is one thing i'll take home
with me when i leave this weekend it's
something i pick up in every country i
visit perspective a reminder that canada
may not be perfect
but we are absolutely
darn lucky
mike armstrong global news kinshasa the
democratic republic of the congo
from pests to heroes next how rats could
become critical critters
when disaster strikes we turn to dogs
for help with search and rescue
operations after all they're called
man's best friend for a reason
rats on the other hand have a bad rap
though as redmond shannon explains
researchers in africa are trying to turn
the rodents into rescuers
man's best friend may soon have some
smaller teammates on the search and
rescue squad
say hello to hero rats these rodents are
in training in tanzania to help
researchers locate and communicate with
earthquake victims how would that work
exactly let the researchers explain
typically with dogs they just go around
the perimeter of a debris site but with
their rats we're hoping they can
actually penetrate inside the debris and
get closer to victims
the rats will wear tiny backpacks kind
of like in paw patrol or batman's
utility belt it has a camera a precision
location transmitter and even a two-way
radio that rescuers could use to speak
with anyone trapped when they get close
to a human they'll trigger a switch
that's
integrated into this backpack
and that will give us
in theory a very precise location of
exactly where those victims are heading
of course it may not be for everyone you
can imagine a traumatized person buried
under rubble for hours or days may not
want to be suddenly confronted with a
rat so one thing that we've been
considering is that they might play a
message like an audio recording that
says something like i am a rescue rat
i'm well trained i'm here to help you
something along those lines the ngo of
popo has already trained rats for other
heroic missions such as sniffing out
landmines and even detecting
tuberculosis the goal is to eventually
deploy fully trained rats to earthquake
zones in turkey and one of them is
actually named after my nephew his name
is daniel
and so i'm very biased and he's one of
my favorites because he's top performing
but the main reason is that he's really
sweet and cuddly even if you don't agree
you can sponsor the program by adopting
a rat and potentially saving a life
remember not all heroes wear capes some
wear backpacks redmond shannon global
news london
to the very first hero in many of our
lives happy father's day
it is my first weekend as anchor of
global national and on a personal note i
wanted to thank the man who got me here
my dad and biggest fan came to canada as
an immigrant in the 70s he had no idea
that his daughter would one day anchor a
national newscast and for the past 22
years he's been sending me a note or
give me a phone call after every single
broadcast
he unknowingly reigns two journalists my
brother is also one and it's because of
his insatiable curiosity about the world
i mean he wake us up with news clippings
to teach us about politics and democracy
and he asks more questions than any
journalist i know happy father's day dad
we love you
that's global national for this sunday
night nito garcia will be with you
tomorrow until next time take care of
yourselves and each other good night
[Music]
you